it's safe to say Kylie Jenner is the  queen of makeup and it's hard to  remember what she looks like without all  the glam look no further than this  flawless makeup free selfie Kylie shared  on Instagram no signs of lip kits or KY  shadows here instead the 19 year old  puts her adorable freckles on full  display amazing still Kylie cosmetics is  killing the game but as the mini Beauty  mogul told ET running your own business  isn't easy I feel like you can't be in  your family and not have some kind of  business savvy mindset you know does it  come natural to you um I don't know if  it would have come so naturally my  mother wasn't who she is  and I feel like she has a huge influence  on all of us and she kind of just taught  us to be like great businesswomen do  what you love I feel like I like to do  stuff that I'm passionate about and  believe in because if I don't then I  won't be as like feel involved and like  happy about what I'm doing